hi Olivia hi ketta you are so poppin
right now oh I think so are you oh you
look amazing I appreciate that
complimenting yes we're having a moment
um so let's talk about the rook really
cool to see you on this show what drew
you to it
you know I really love psychological
thrillers and and I really I love like
the old-school British spy shows and
movies and so this was just the the
perfect combination of that and you know
the opportunity to work with these
people and to work with such a great
ensemble especially with you know
amazing women like Joe Lee Richardson
and I'm a green wall was like just it
was just really too hard not to to jump
on board to do yeah does your character
have a superpower well none of these
characters have superpowers does a
supernatural ability right yeah there is
a you know this show is a psychological
thriller with supernatural undertones
but all of our abilities are based in
you know reality with what we all have
but there has been some kind of
biological change that has increased
some of our abilities so my character
has an incredible strength so she can
like push out a like a like a dead bolt
with just her thumb yeah so and then
there's some people who can hear a
whisper in a crowd of thousands or see
for miles so it's just whatever our
regular human abilities are but some of
us have this biological change that has
intensified our abilities yeah if you
could have I guess a special ability in
real life you know which one would you I
would definitely want the ability to fly
to fly wouldn't you want that
what is your ability where are you going
and have you been you live in LA the
traffic here is horror okay you know
what that's a really great can you
imagine so much of your life is wasted
like in traffic it's true what would you
want I want to go and it's gonna be
invisible
what would you where you go I just want
to see like certain Chanel bags being
made just like you were they come out
you're just gonna go to China No
that's why all of that stuff is made did
you know that all of it like almost
everything so you know when they say
like made in China are made in sorry
when they say like made in Italy or
France or Switzerland like something can
just be like stitched one last stitch to
be technically made in so they make it
all in China and then the last couple
stitches or the last like screws of a
Rolex get wages kill I was I had a dream
you did to him to be invisible to go
watch them now a female no not even that
just to be invisible you go creep and
see what a creep is different but more
just what you really 1/8 it when we're
not on camera I know what you're gonna
say when you're invisible she's like I
want to keep on that ex boyfriend I'm
gonna keep on the current boy current
man that's too much power I think to be
so invisible okay so I think I get bored
but if then you also have to like you're
invisible you gotta like get on the
plane so take that flight over yeah you
do right that's true why you can fly
anything I thought about this I've
thought about it and by the way if I'm
creeping on somebody if I wanted to I
just fly out right you gotta like walk
out invisible so let's talk about your
character in the show can you just
describe her for me what does she like
my character is the actually the only
American character in the show and she
is she is she's basically the u.s. eyes
looking into this really corrupt British
agency you know there's the American
side there's the the British side and we
are all you know part of one big
organization however there is something
extremely corrupt going on and the
British agency so as my character is
trying to figure out what's going on
there she also has her own agenda
something very personal that she's
trying to figure out as well you've been
very outspoken I think that's what I
love about you the most is that you know
you really just share how you feel and
you help a lot of people when you do
that and I know you you know let your
hand
with the Miche movement and time's up
and you you were outspoken after all of
that how would you say the industry has
changed you know are we further along
now or do you still think that we have
so much more work to do I think that's a
great question I think you know
when the first story is about Harvey
Weinstein first came out yeah 2017
I remember feeling just a sense of I
wouldn't call it like shock but it was a
disbelief of just is it really going to
take hold if people do people where
people really care then I was really
surprised that they were actually
repercussions and such a huge support
system around the people that were
speaking out because the things that you
know happened to me mmm you know
actually were brought up years ago and
by the by the person who did it and the
world just kind of accepted him and
believed his lies and even when he had
to admit that he lied about me and
admitted to the things that he did I
just kept rolling you know rolling
forward so all of a sudden here we are
you know though for me though you know
the stuff that happened to me was the
years before but it all came to light in
like 2011
and there was no big change nobody
seemed to care back then and all of a
sudden here we are in 2017 and people
cared and that was such a an amazing
moment I was just kind of it's kind of
like you're you wake up and you're like
is this a dream or not a dream is it
this is really actually happening and
it's it's a new day and that was such a
great feeling and I think that you know
there is still more to do obviously
there's a lot more we have to you know
eradicate the disease roots within the
infrastructure and a lot of that has to
do with the not just the abusers but the
people who collude to keep them in power
that's so important because there's a
lot of people who turn a blind eye
because it helps them but I think the
biggest thing that has changed in the
world since the me2 movement you know
first came about in this iteration in
2017 is that there are a lot of white
men who are now aware of their existence
so you know if you ask any woman
minority or LGBTQ member how often
they're aware of their existence they'll
say every day and so now you have all
these men who have never really thought
about that and now they're asking
questions like oh am I not allowed to
hug her am I not allowed to touch her if
I say this
make people upset and for the first time
they're aware of their existence and
they're aware of like what they say and
how it might affect other people and you
know we've seen them express in the
media their frustration with that but
you know it's not a bad place to be you
know it's actually where the rest of us
live in the world you know we have to be
aware of what we do and won't be saying
how it affects other people and so I
think that's been a really great thing
that's happened is that we have all you
know this entire group of people who
have never had to think about that
before who are now aware of it yeah I
love that
I saw your birthday shout out to
Jennifer Aniston oh yeah you were just
like commending her for being you know
strong and protecting you in an
interview what does she like Jen is such
a just a nice person like really very
grounded and real and also very aware of
her worth and what she has created and
when she's built in this world and I'm
just a very like calming person to be
around you know um I think there are a
lot of people I've worked with people
who when you're working together they're
really nice and they're really nice up
like up through press because they know
that that you are gonna be asked about
them and then after that they kind of
fall off or you can see you know you
really can see that they are more
duplicitous then people would have
imagined and if I was to tell those
names I think that people would it be
like telling you that Santa Claus
doesn't exist but Jen is just it's just
a like a real person who really cares
about things that she speaks about and
isn't you know flighty and and it's just
somebody that like in that moment I
talked about you know it was just you
know it's a small moment but in this
business you know you see people just
look out for themselves so much and or
watch somebody else like kind of flail
and and and be there on the other side
to be like I'll that's tough but you
know in that moment I remember I just
I'm just so surprised that she that she
would jump in
like that and recognize that it wasn't
an appropriate question and you know I
didn't even have to feel uncomfortable
because she was just right there and
there was just such a strength to that
and and really she was talking as a
human being she wasn't you know being a
celebrity or an actor or you know um
even thinking about the camera being
pointed at her she was just you know
seeing something as a human being that
she felt thought was just you know
yeah it just just didn't feel good in
that moment yeah x-men Dark Phoenix June
mm-hmm
what can you tell us I'm really I just
want to know I mean I I can't say
anything because last time I said a
little bit they sent me a note but I'm
not in it a note or an email did you
well I got a message from my publicist
okay but I wasn't allowed to say if I'm
in it or not but I will tell you that
I'm not in it
cuz didn't really yeah I'm not in it
because I've been so tired of people
asking me from it I wasn't allowed to
say if I was in her or not what I was
filming predator at the time and so
there wasn't time for me to to film it
and so um so I'm like dying okay yeah
fun facts fun facts but I haven't hardly
heard much about it um yeah awesome well
that's what I can tell you is that I'm
not in it I was filming predator at the
time series Oh the rook is an awesome
show
you're lovely on it you're living in
real life thank you so much and it was
great chatting with your not good to see
you too these guys thank you
you